I'm gonna do two different ways and I'm
fully like I can believe i'll show you
want to be like really really i heard by
the time I show you the second one
you've got okay I set this right so how
are we going to do this I want to make
two triangles okay and I've got one two
three four five six spots to choose from
okay now what this is a little bit like
is about seating two groups of people
West to triangles two groups of people
okay now I want you to think look at how
this is arranged right I know I know
there are like gaps that can thing but
this is a circular arrangements question
isn't it like they are literally in a
circle okay so therefore on a circular
asianess question the first thing I have
to do is have to fix someone in position
okay now obviously all of these points
are going to get used in some in one
triangle or the other okay so let's just
say let's just pick a spot ok I'm going
to make that one of the verses in one of
the triangles okay all right now I need
to complete this triangle need to
complete this triangle I've already
picked one point won't you say fix one
point as one of the vertices of the
triangle is to complete this triangle
how many more vertices do I need to and
how many options do I have to choose
from to get those 25 choose two points
to complete that triangle I've just
mentioned and you said they were fire to
choose from and I need to choose to it
doesn't it okay um y equals the ice
doesn't chase it doesn't still it's
still set okay so this is this is my
number right now if you want to go this
way I've now sat down one of the groups
okay and they've made a triangle okay
then the other group the other tribe
will comes along okay now doesn't matter
where they serious it doesn't matter
where they sit for the reason you said
to me right at the beginning that order
doesn't matter these three guys come
along and they've just got to occupy
whatever is left over like suppose this
is what I get out of the five seats you
this is one of the ways right and you're
one two three there's only one way
form a triangle with this right only one
way okay so a fixed one point chosen to
so I've made the first triangle the
other triangle has no more choices okay
does that make sense so therefore number
one I've got to pick out my six vertices
in the first place they're my green
things and then number two I've got to
choose triangle choose a triangle and
I'm done so this way of doing it is to
say in summary with my total it's 12 to
6 times 5 choose 2 does that make sense
or x 5 to 2 times 1 okay I believe 5
choose 2 is 1010 and this number i think
is it's big it's gonna pick them up like
this was big and this is further it
closer to the center can someone tell me
what it is 9 24 x 10 x 1 so there's my
number okay now maybe not convinced by
that that's okay Aaron you have a
different pair of numbers there you've
gone about it a different way do you are
you confident up to explain how you did
it if you're not I will oh yeah give it
a shot give it a shot I'll be your i'll
be your brain scribe would you like me
to do so uh destroy any triangle
from the six let's do this one yeah yeah
so for each triangle that you have there
is one other triangle that corresponds
with that final rule yeah okay go and so
just looking at the red chamber right
now there are six see three options from
that okay pause 63 63 options to drive
this triangle do you see that's exactly
the same problem I had up here right
it's just that I got less to choose from
that's why it's 63 not 12 c 3 so so far
so good yeah so there are 63 options for
the first triangle get going and so as
you keep coming through all those seen
three options right you will reach so
for example in that example right there
you will reach an example that so the
red one is now in the fifties you want
that green one so just what did you
catch what he just said there this is
one instance this is one instance of of
the six see three options right and as I
keep listing out all of the options
eventually one of those 63 is going to
be this guy right does that make sense
yes okay get going yeah and so because
that that means that now you have
accounted for that yes pause help me out
here how much has he / counted by he's
exactly over counted by double because
of what he said before this red one
already makes this dotted green one one
of the triangles it's already been
chosen and this will always be the case
for every single one he's exactly
doubled up does that make sense so this
over counts by a factor of two right do
you want to finish it off is there much
more that
the total would be your bottom policy
six yep I'm 63 yeah because you can't if
you / perfect okay Chelsea six is still
924 63 o coincidentally is 20 and you
still win on your night doesn't you have
informed not bad okay so if you ever
struggle to convince yourself of
something like your I think I have an
air tar and very frequent you black mmm
not sure try it again think about it
some other way that's the hard part and
then see if you can come if you get
different answers then you might know
them to know something's wrong here it's
one or the other and you can keep on
going well there's another where you
would do do the thing your way and then
somehow managed to get more ways yeah
okay other ways of like knowing that
you've done something wrong is when you
are you've clearly exceeded you know
like the different conditions you've got
so you're like wait I've got more
options with more restrictions how does
that work all right now I'm rapidly
running out of space let's have a look
at Part C it's got two parts over which
are really into two halves of the same
question two sides in the same clinic
have a look it says in how many such
pairs these are all the pairs we can get
right 9240 and how many such pairs will
the triangles not overlap and part to
overlap okay now do you see why what was
the clue that told me oh these are too
hard to the same question yeah ah
there's another one if compliments okay
well are conjugates you get the idea but
these are it's like you're either this
or your that whatever those are all of
its you know like this you know it back
from surd's those are conjugates right
you're thinking about complete set
that's okay these two combined should be
this summer do you agree with that yeah
okay now just for the sake of time I'm
rather than you get you to have a think
about it i will show you the way that I
thought about it and maybe you can come
up with another way right you remember I
said how do you look at these six
circled points the ones that I've chosen
they are kind of like a new version of
the original problem just smaller okay
so with me I'd like you to replicate
just this six points just draw me one
two three four five six okay let's just
imagine now i have chosen those six so
the rest of the circle doesn't exist to
me okay these are the options i'm
choosing with you i'm going to do a
couple more and you'll see why in a
second and now i'm on a mission right
here I was just like what put your
triangles wherever you like but now I
got some conditions for this okay so how
can I arrange my triangles so that they
don't overlap have a look when I chose
these guys over here you notice I chose
these guys there was no choice they had
to overlap okay um they are only a very
small number of pairs of triangles that
will not overlap let's just draw one
where would you like me let's call these
on one two three four five and six so I
want to give me three numbers that will
form a triangle so the other triangle
won't overlap any time zones yeah what's
your three one two three is all I need
right because once you've got that
triangle right the other three points
have no choice so they have to be four
five and six great I have two
non-overlapping frames can someone give
me another one yeah one same setting up
12 64 k so next up and top and down 1
i'm very good okay can someone give me
another one yeah okay so if i go 165
that's this one but the other way right
so once is five like that that forces 2
3 4 to be the other triangle okay now
when you have a look at these bed you
look cool um surprisingly surprisingly
that's it go ahead and try and find
another pair of triangles that don't
overlap that's all the wage okay I guess
the way I would describe this now trying
to get this back to the language of the
question
here's a squeeze this in Part C Part 1 2
not overlap right the Train wasn't
remember i numbered these right just to
try and get my head round and describe
what's going on to not overlap how to
look at the qualities the attributes
that all of these arrangements have in
common okay just think about the green
triangle for instance I have one two
three there's no way I coulda done one
two and four all right can you see one
two and four is it going to cause me a
problem why because yeah that's right
you got to get someone's got to get to
three and two and four have blocked the
way right you see that so the problem is
if you have non consecutive numbers like
124 125 or 12 anything else you're gonna
be in trouble right so to not overlap we
need consecutive numbers but i might add
one more thing right because this is a
circular arrangement right consecutive
numbers back might be like one two three
two three four four five six right but
but um 612 is this one and that was okay
six and one are not consecutive numbers
are bank okay but in this circle they
are so you can see this in a bunch of
different ways you could just say
consecutive numbers in a circle there is
a more specific word for this which is
that these numbers are Kansai click they
are on in circle that's literally what
consequence means so to not overlap when
you consecutive concise like points for
each triangle and there's only three
ways to do it was only three wet you can
see once you if you want a picture this
guy is green one he's kind of like
spinning clockwise run around the top
see that he's here and then he moves up
to hear it moves down to here if he were
to rotate one more time he'd be back to
hear right you see that in exactly the
same way that Aaron mentioned before
it's like you've already done that
you've over counted okay so therefore we
know there are 12 c six ways to pick the
three the six points and then within
those six points and only one two three
ways to make sure they don't overlap
that's it um yeah why did I do this
because I still have to pick out the
point for the triangles to inhabit right
so I've still got 12 to begin with and
then I pick out my six and then I form a
triangle okay um come on we can do this
one that's 220 7020 772 done hey do I
need to answer part two yeah it's it's
all the other ones it's all the other
ones right so it'll be 9240 take away
all the ones that don't overlap every
single other one must overlap so that's
why it's the answer the carpet